Donald Trump has a ton of crazy theories which
he's
willing to say publicly, and it turns out
that, much like with many people, this is
actually not that
rare, there's an entire other even crazier
narrative of what he's willing to say privately
and share
with his inner circle.
And there's a New York magazine piece that
exposes a lot of this stuff and
we're linking to that piece.
So, earlier this week, we learned from what
was an I believe of Vanity Fair, piece that
Donald
Trump is concerned, that journalists traveling
on Air Force One my sort of weaponized the
virus
and deliberately infect him with it.
That's already pretty wacky.
And Donald Trump, now we have learned privately
is raging about all
sorts of completely absurd notions for example,
from privately is furious that he's not getting
credit
for stopping travel from China.
Now, of course he did it way too late.
Only partially.
We found countless flights still landing in
the
United States from China, after Trump said
he had cut it off.
Trump privately is raging at the media for
even covering what is now a pandemic per the
show, and
is convinced that the media simply is How
to get Trump.
So dude, you're bundling everything you're
doing everything wrong, even the things you're
doing,
you're lying about.
Trump believes per the New York magazine Magazine
piece either because he
decided or people convinced him Trump believes
he is personally way healthier than both Bernie
Sanders and Joseph are by a junior and that,
therefore, he's less at risk of the virus
or if he were to
catch the virus.
This is the President, who lies about his
height to avoid being clinically obese, the
president who doesn't exercise the president
who eats endless fast food and barely walks
around and
the President who had to have call a flower
mixed into his mashed potatoes to get some
actual
vegetables into his diet.
He thinks he's healthier than Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders.
Now, if you watched his address to the nation
on Wednesday evening, you probably noticed
that his
right eye as I mentioned, was almost completely
swollen shut, you might have noticed that
he was
with experiencing labored breathing, he didn't
look well, but in any case he thinks he's
gonna be
fine, but Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden won.
If they catch the disease.
Very, very weird.
Donald Trump believes, that the virus isn't
really that big of a threat because his friends
don't yet
have, it and his friends don't get no, people
who have it.
Trump believes that without any intervention,
the virus situation may indeed solve itself,
which is
of course not how pandemics work pandemics,
require interventions.
And Donald Trump's entire
03/13/20 Page 2 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
public spectacle may seem to be merely from
political pressure not because Donald Trump
actually
believes that it is necessary.
This is why these things spread so quickly,
before we understood germ theory and the like.
People didn't realize that our actions are
what determine what happens that you have
to look at is
water spreading a disease, is it contact,
is it airborne is it arises, is it via bodily
fluid?
Understanding
the stuff washing hands when the world of
medicine, understood.
Oh, when you wash your hands
between patients at the hospital, you're much
better off.
Obviously, it's not clear what if any of this
stuff Donald Trump believes, and that's why
this last belief is the most outrageous one
because if
Donald Trump deep down believes that without
human intervention, this is all going to resolve
itself then it's going to continue to spread
while he does the absolute minimum or lies
in front of the
public.
That insurance companies have decided to waive
all copays for treatment when in fact they
have not.
This is horrifying, this is scary stuff, we
have very little that we can do to change
his mind, since
he's in an isolated echo chamber of brown
dosing and Fox News.
And it seems as though if the New York Magazine
piece is to be believed, it seems as though
even
the things he is doing, he is doing out of
political pressure, and political posturing
and because the
stock market is imploding, not because he
actually believes that it's necessary, his
ignorance has a
body count associated with it.
And sometimes when we say a body count, we
mean a political body
count people who have lost their positions
they weren't re­elected, because of something
that
Donald Trump did, which had to trickle down
in fact.
No, no, no, we're talking about an actual
body
count here.
And in the meantime, again, let's start testing,
I know Trump believes if the number of
cases explodes which it would if we start
testing, because a ton of people already have
it if that were
to happen from things, it would be terrible
for him, and maybe it would in some sense,
but the
important thing is that would show that this
is less deadly, and it would also really encourage
people who might be a symptomatic to self­quarantine
and to stay home, people who otherwise
would never be tested.
We've gotta start testing large numbers of
people.
This is not going to get
any better for as long as this person is in
charge, unless people can take control for
themselves.
And
so far it doesn't seem that the drum is administration
is allowing anybody to do that.
Let me know once again, what are you doing?
Are you modifying your behavior because of
the
virus?
Are you changing your day­to­day?
Let me know on Twitter, I'm on Twitter at
De Hackman.
Make sure that you were following me there.
We have a very, very big program for you today.
I am going to be hearing from people in the
audience about what's going on with the primary,
we are still in the middle of a primary despite
the
fact that we are also in the middle of dealing
with a pandemic crisis and much more coming
up t